[Applaudissements]
de la musique jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
c'est ce que promettent qu'ils faveur
pompiers de tours pour leur traditionnel
bal du 13 juillet mais cette année est
un peu particulière puisque la caserne
fête ses 50 ans faire ces festivités
pour faire plaisir aux tourangeaux
tourangelle puisqu'on va tous les jours
chez eux mais ça serait sympa que on
s'est dit ça serait sympa qui viennent
chez nous au moins pour une fois une
fois de l'année qu'on aimerait bien
table et surtout sept mille personnes
environ
ce soir ils seront quatre chanteurs à se
relayer avant de passer le témoin un dj
set après midi était donc l'occasion
d'affiner les derniers réglages on est
en train de faire les essais pour le son
hier soir on a fait les lumières comme
vous voyez la scène est quand même
relativement importante
donc en fait il faut absolument qu'on
sache au niveau des micros ce que ça va
donner au niveau du son et puis tout à
l'heure vous imaginez avec des milliers
de personnes ici à nous écouter chanter
c'est un vrai concert un vrai concert en
plein air donc
donc voilà je suis très stressée mais ça
va te faire comme chaque année il ya
aucun problème je suis pas inquiète
je sais que le public répondra présent
et que ça se passera très bien et la
préparation concerne également la
logistique puisque comme pour les feux
d'artifice la préfecture a donné
plusieurs consignes de sécurité la rue
charles gounod est barrée à la
circulation par des plots béton pour
éviter toute intrusion de véhicules on a
un service de sécurité privé comme les
années précédentes qui effectue une
fouille et qui filtrent les entrées
voilà on met le maximum de ce qui est
dans nos capacités pour que la sécurité
soit au rendez vous pour ce soir même si
la majorité des pompiers sera de la
partie la caserne restera opérationnel